you guys all heard about that term 4x4
I can't remember the uh actress's name
but a week or two ago
um
Leonardo DiCaprio was getting [__] on by
other celebrities because he now has a
19 year old uh Israeli model girlfriend
and I don't know if you know you guys
know this but Leonardo DiCaprio I can't
remember if he's 43 or 46 I think he's
closer to 46 so he's in his late 40s
and he's dating a 19 year old so of
course you know celebrity uh women lost
their [__] and blew up
um Twitter and there was a Swedish woman
I can't remember her name
uh but anyway she was nicknamed four by
four it was a hilarious title that said
something along the lines of uh Leonardo
DiCaprio is shamed for 19 year old by
four by four and the definition of four
by four was this woman had four kids
from four different fathers this
celebrity chastising uh our friend
anyway
let's get back to this
um Becky knows what she wants but it's
just but she doesn't understand that men
don't want her she's trying to attract
bees with vinegar and doesn't understand
they want honey
when you remove fur babies the 17
decorative pillows the Ikea Decor Becky
is basically a man and that's not what
men want
now I get Flack when I correct women and
I explain that beautiful women aren't
the prize high value men putting a dent
in the universe are beautiful women are
common with top shelf men that they all
want simply aren't
the problem that top shelf man sorry the
problem that top shelf men face is that
beautiful and agreeable women are also
scarce it's Becky's disconnect from
reality of what men want and are
impossibly high standards for a man that
keeps her signal lonely and angry
I'm not going to read much more of the
rest of this because I'm going to give
away too much to the chapter but it
actually gets better we talk about
Becky's married life when she finds the
uh simp to wife her up I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full-length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out